>>Jalen: I was, I think,
three years old
when I first went on the computer.
I was five when I got my Game
Boy, used to play that every day.
It was just so fun, so I equally
use my Game Boy and my computer,
so I get an hour to play each so that
I would do basketball during the time
that I wasn't doing technology.
And when during the times I wasn't
doing anything I would just lay
down and chill.
>>Zoey, Zoey.
>>At seven years old, that's really
when I started drawing a lot.
I like it, it's fun, and the
people compliment on my drawings,
so I think that's kind of fun.
And then at 10 years old,
when I went to 5th grade,
I made my first comic book.
And after that I went
into sixth grade,
and that's when I got my laptop, and
then I started using that more often.
I joined the DYM program.
>>Akili: If you know your
account, pull it up on your laptop.
>>The Digital Youth Network
was really trying to look
to see how now the students
are really inundated
with all this new technology.
How does that impact how kids
socialize, and then how does that,
in turn, impact how
they learn as well?
>>There's a project
called "Editing Project 1."
Everybody got that?
>>The kid can come in and they
can do digital music production,
graphic design and animation, game
design or digital video production.
>>Why do they go slow motion?
Why were they going
slow motion, though?
>>Akili: The kids on
their own are jumping
across from all these different
mediums, so we really need to kind
of explore all of them as
well and try to support kids
to become better producers
and consumers, and critique is
within all these different pieces.
>>So Remix World is kind of like
MySpace, kind of like Facebook mixed
with a little bit of YouTube as
well, so you can go on there.
You can post your own
videos that y'all make.
You can post the music
that you're making.
I saw that you were remixing
a song online already.
>>I did.
>>Akili: Remix World is a contained
social-networking site that's only
open to our students and our mentors.
>>So the rest of the kids
in the school can actually
see what you guys are doing,
and you can also go in and
you can comment and critique
on what everybody else has done.
>>So, the idea is that students
for us are already spending all
of their time on all these different
social-networking communities
around the Web.
Why can't we re-appropriate
those kind of tools
and then there's more
formal educational context?
>>Jalen: I post up videos, poems and
just whatever I thought was, like --
that my opinion was it was cool.
I would post up on the Remix World
to see what other people thought.
Sometimes on YouTube I get worse
feedback than the Remix World.
Well, I'm okay with that, though,
because I know there's a lot
of people on YouTube that're
better than me at what I do,
because they've been doing it longer
and they know how to do it better.
I accept that and I'll try harder
to make mine just as good as theirs.
>>That's one of the
shoes I've created.
First I just took a layout of the
normal Nike Dunkers just plain white,
and after I add in colors
and different, like, images.
When I created this shoe I
was thinking of Halloween,
so I put in some 3D pumpkins almost
all across the front of the shoe.
>>Scoop: Have your seat.
Do your thing, sit back
and get out of your way.
>>Jalen has always been
creative, always, and he did that.
In his mind kind of
thinks a little different.
He's very open, and to see him fall
into something that can connect
with where his mind goes
sometimes and be able
to have him do something
tangible, it's amazing to see that.
>>Jalen: "A Division to Our Own" was
a movie that we made in the summer.
I enjoyed it.
I was a graphic artist,
so technically what I did was
I created all the posters.
>>I decided to use fingerprints,
because that's your identity,
and I put them in different colors
for different races like that.
>>You can sit wherever you'd like.
>>Jalen: The movie was technically
about a class, which was in Room 201,
and how races were segregated
and that they then
discussed about racism.
>>At the top it says "what divides
us," so they're all divided apart,
and that there on the bottom,
it says "what unites us"
and then they're all in one circle.
>>Tracy: It feeds into his academics.
He's reading.
He's learning and he's figuring
out how to incorporate all
of the technology into that.
And I think it's teaching him
different ways to think about things
and to figure out problems, so I see
him becoming even a better student
as a result.
>>Jalen: Sometimes we have
assignments like book reports
and stuff, so what
I usually like to do
for my book report is make a comic,
where I have, like, little squares
where I could put, like,
some pictures in there
and have the speech bubble
coming out and it says, "Hi.
This is a book report from Jalen
Jackson," yadda, yadda, yadda,
all that stuff that you
need in the book report.
And sometimes we have
to do PowerPoints.
Sometimes we do games,
all that stuff.
>>Akili: Jaden has been in video
games for a couple of years now,
so last year they were
using a tool called Scratch.
>>Jalen: Scratch is a program where
you kind of make your own characters,
and after that you edit their
actions so that they could probably,
like, run maybe or anything.
>>Akili: Then all you got
to do is tell the program
that when I press left or
something that I want it
to do the walking animation.
>>Jalen: Yes, and after
that I put it into my game.
>>Akili: Jalen is typical
in the sense
that I think he embraces exploration,
but I think he's a little
bit more unique in the sense
that he takes it a step
further on his own very often,
so he decides that he likes anime,
but now on his own he decided
that he was going to learn how
to create an anime music video.
>>Jalen: The idea was
cut up different clips.
Then I pick a really good song that
I think will go good with the clips,
and I thought I'd just
put it all together.
>>Scoop: He's really into this,
and me sitting there literally
creating a video, a music video.
First four or five hours and he
have a three-minute video together.
Six months later, four or five
hours he'd had four or five,
four videos together,
so it was like, wow.
And he's very, very,
very passionate about it.
>>What's television class
going to be like, Jalen?
>>Jalen: I think we're
recording this week.
>>I need some sort of outline
what you guys are going
to do on your show.
>>Jalen: They want us to be able
to make a movie using all
those skills of writing.
They want it to have
a good storyline.
>>So president
>>Jalen: They want it
to have a certain amount
of vocabulary that'll be appropriate
for a seventh-grade level,
and they want it to
be at least something
that would be interesting to watch.
>>Right now I'm editing the clips
shorter so that it kind of looks more
like a movie and not just
like pictures just
floating out of the air.
So I'm going to see how
that works out first.
The stuff goes faster...
>>Tracy: Jalen's a silly 12-year-old.
>>Scoop: And he's proud
of being silly.
>>Shut up, give me my game.
>>Tracy: And he likes being
silly, he likes being silly.
>>Jalen: [inaudible] our show too.
>>No, he doesn't.
>>Tracy: He always has an
idea, always has an answer.
If I say, "Jay, can you not do that?"
it's always a good reason
for why it should be done.
So, I mean, he's a
typical 12-year-old.
>>Thirty minutes, so now I am
eligible to play video games.
>>What I want to do when I grow
up is I want to be a cartoonist
and a video game maker and artist.
Technically they all
come together, though.
So, I think that this -- all
of this graphic design, gaming,
all of this stuff that I do
will contribute to my cartooning
and gaming one day, all these
technology programs that I do.
>>For more information on what works
in public education
go to edutopia.org